so i'm going to talk today about a
number of things sort of around the
general space of what programming tools
do people doing data science need and as
mentioned i'm going to focus especially
on the needs of domain experts from
non-technical domains
i'm also going to be talking about
sort of what it has looked like to do
work in sort of the program synthesis
and program languages space in the past
aiming to work for for end users and
maybe not always landing on something
that is usable or useful so i'm going to
talk a bit in that context about need
finding to make things that are going to
be useful and then formative assessment
to actually
figure out if things are usable
so i want to start by acknowledging that
this talk is going to touch on a bunch
of awesome work by my students the folks
in my lab
i'm not gonna go through all of them
here but i will pop up the pictures
again when we get to to their work
uh we have been calling ourselves the
the plate lab for uh basically talking
about approachable and inclusive
programming languages and tools
and these are some of the amazing
students
all the good stuff is from them
i also want to talk about one of the the
primary goals of this lab which is
to bridge the gap with folks from the
social sciences who they have various
needs
but they don't necessarily know how to
do the traditional programming processes
that we would expect from folks to get
their automation needs accomplished
and the reason i say social science
visionaries here is these are fields
that have
really long histories sometimes
centuries long and they're really
somewhat set in their ways in some cases
and so you have to go out and find folks
who are willing to try techniques that
might be somewhat riskier start doing
work that hasn't necessarily been
possible for folks in their space before
and so building really strong close
collaborations with folks
on the the social science side has been
really critical for our lab and actually
getting tools adopted by them and making
sure that they are actually useful and
usable for them
so that's going to be a thread that runs
through today's talk
a little quick background on on me and
sort of what has shaped my lab's
direction i started from a primarily
programming languages background both at
sort of the undergrad level and for the
first part of my my grad school
but eventually realized that i really
was going to be needing a bunch of hci
techniques in order to do the work i
wanted to do
well
and so one of the big things that i've
been thinking about a lot both sort of
over the course of my phd and as i've
been forming my lab is how we should be
integrating techniques from hci into a
programming languages practice
and so i'm going to have a little road
map to guide us through what we're
chatting about today so first
i mentioned that we've been thinking a
lot in my lab about how pl should be
integrating techniques from hci i'm then
going to do a somewhat deep dive on
helena which is a particular tool that
we've developed that's focused on
basically being usable and useful for
social scientists
and i'm going to talk about how that
tool and various other tools in the
general space have actually shaped our
approach for integrating hci into pkl
and i'm going to talk a bit about how
this looks so far and what the lab is
sort of up to
so let's start by talking about
sort of the some framing for this talk
which is our thoughts on how pl should
be integrating techniques from hci
uh and so some of this is going to be
pulling on some some stuff that we put
together recently for a little pack-um
article with elena glassman and josh
sunshine
and basically we had been doing a bunch
of work in this general space for a
while
and starting to figure out that you know
as much as there has been work for for
decades and decades on combining hci and
pl there was a particular flavor of it
that was most common right obviously
people knew that you know programmers
are users and they they have some needs
and it's something that people should be
thinking about but most of the stuff
that had actually been done in that
space at least so far
it's focused a lot on evaluation right
so let's build whatever crazy
programming languages tool we have in
mind whatever crazy language feature we
have in mind and then after the fact
maybe we'll put it in front of some
users just to see okay let's now that
we've you know sunk a couple years of
engineering and theory and really hard
work into this now let's put it in front
of users and figure out did we land on
something good
and it's not to say that we shouldn't do
that or that that wasn't a really
awesome sort of piece of progress for
for pl's techniques that has absolutely
improved
a lot of pl work i believe firmly that
that is good stuff that we should be
having going on
but it's not the only way to to land on
good programming tools and in fact it's
probably not the best way to to guide us
to
really effective really usable
programming tools
and so some of the the things that we
wanted to to call out as interesting
things for pl to borrow from hci and for
hci to borrow from pl uh this set of
messages is actually the the things that
we really thought that
the hci side could be using from pl
and so i'll go through these real quick
because these will shape a little bit of
of the work that i'm talking about today
but i'm mostly going to focus on the
next slide which we'll talk about the
other direction
but what we were thinking that the hci
side could really use from the pl side
is in part programming languages are
super powerful right as a interac
interaction way of actually doing tasks
so a way to
interface with some kind of automation
it gives users a lot of control it gives
them really powerful extractions and a
lot of flexibility
then uh on the pl side we've been
developing especially in the last couple
of decades some really amazing
guardrails right there are ways that we
can actually enforce that people are
doing good things with their languages
good things with their tools
and that's pretty cool and pretty useful
for if you are giving someone the full
flexibility of a language how you make
sure that they're actually going to be
able to use it in a way that is safe and
effective
and then the other thing is there's been
all this progress in the program
synthesis space which is basically ways
of turning things that are not
programs or at least not traditional
programs into programs right how do we
take something other than traditional
code use it as a specification in order
to automatically write the programs that
they're going to need and so those are
all techniques that we think can be
really helpful to to a lot of the the
hci goals
and i want to quickly talk about the the
things that the pl side should be
drawing on more from the hci site right
all of these are things that it's not
that they've never been explored but
it's things that we think are under
explored in these spaces so far
so the things that we're really excited
for pl people to start doing more and
i'm going to emphasize a lot this first
one
a lot of need finding right we've had
this long history of people saying okay
this is a problem that i personally have
faced in my programming languages
journey and therefore i'm going to make
this tool that will be useful for
compiler optimizers the 10 compiler
optimizer writers who are working inside
the
c internal scene right whatever the case
is which
absolutely awesome problems it's good
that someone is working on that but
that's not the only way to to find
important problems important needs and
we're really excited about people
starting to
basically go out and look for the kinds
of things that programming languages and
tools can tackle out in the world
another thing is we figured out that you
know not every programming languages
researcher is willing to actually run
formative user studies and so if we want
to make it practical for these folks to
actually make good design choices in the
process of developing languages of
developing tools we really are going to
have to give them some kind of a
shortcut and we think that's probably
going to end up having to be behavioral
theory if we can develop enough of it
that folks can start making these
decisions without running user studies
of their own
and then also this idea of iterative
refinement so believe it or not this is
not actually super common in mainstream
pl
often the idea is you start with a goal
you proceed until you have reached that
goal
you then evaluate it and that's kind of
where we land at least on the on the
user evaluation side right there's not a
lot of okay let's put this in front of
somebody let's see what's working what's
not working let's go back let's let's
iterate
and so making sure that we're actually
getting that kind of formative input we
think is is really important and we'd
like to see more of that happening on
the pl side
okay so those are our three sort of
thrusts of things that we are hoping
to have uh showing up more in in
programming languages and that's going
to shape some of the work that you'll
see today
so an example of where pl has started to
try this
uh i mentioned briefly program synthesis
the idea of turning some spec something
other than code and turning it into
a piece of program right a piece of code
you might have heard specifically of
programming by example where the idea is
that we have inputs and output pairs and
what we want to do is actually generate
the program that converts each input
into its paired output
or you might have heard of the even more
specific thing of programming by
demonstration where you're getting the
input output pairs but you're also
getting the sequence of actions the user
took in order to actually transform the
input into the output
so
a little while back i gave a little pop
quiz to a synthesis workshop and i asked
them which of these things they had
thought so
i am going to use program synthesis to
make task x easier
a ton of hands for that
i am going to use program synthesis to
make this task accessible to more
programmers
also a ton of hands for that
this last one making tasks accessible to
non-programmers not as many hands but
still some hands right so this is
definitely something that people in this
space
are thinking
about
then i followed it up with pop quiz 2
which was do you regularly use a program
synthesis tool no counting your own one
that you're building
and so i'll actually ask this question
of the folks in this
hall is anyone here regularly using a
program synthesis tool
all right we got one answer is it one
that you built okay it's not one that
you built all right great
and then the next question was what
about your non-coder friends
anyone non-coder friends using program
synthesis tools
okay so we've got one hand for that
first question so that's pretty good
actually that's better than i got at the
program synthesis workshop uh but
basically the lesson that i was trying
to to emphasize to them was as much as
we've been thinking about these goals of
trying to make tasks easier trying to
make them more accessible to broader
audiences we kind of haven't been
landing on it yet and i think a lot of
that is about not having listened to
uh those those lessons from the orange
box right not having actually put tools
in front of users to see what's working
not having actually iterated on uh the
the things that we are demanding from
them in order to get to the programs
that they want
so that's something that i was trying to
emphasize to that audience is okay how
can we get to a better position
and basically the the background here is
that a lot of folks if they've seen a
couple of demos of end user program
synthesis they expect that the breakdown
of people liking it versus disliking it
is probably going to look something like
this
and in fact if we look at the history of
tools in this space unfortunately it
looks more like this right we have
learned all of these things about
what makes programs that this is tools
that actually won't get adopted that
users don't actually particularly like
and unfortunately not all that much
about what they actually do like
i'm going to provide a quick call out to
some work by these two students that is
specifically studying okay if we put a
program synthesizer in front of a
programming novice maybe someone from
cs1 uh what are they going to actually
be able to do with it what is going to
be confusing what is not going to be
confusing uh what does it take to make
it actually learnable so that will be
coming out eventually but it's a little
early to actually report on it so i'll
leave that there for now
okay
so what we're going to talk about for
maybe half ish of this talk is a
particular domain where we do have two
decades of synthesis tools that have
never quite met user needs and what it
took to actually get to the point of of
meeting user needs
so now we're doing or we're switching
into our topic on doing a deepish dive
on helena
so
my first question is how many people
here have written a web scraper
okay more hands than for use of program
synthesis daily so that makes a lot of
sense no yeah okay so that was a solid
number of hands so i think folks here
probably already understand that there's
a lot of value in web data i think
people are increasingly realizing how
much you can actually get out of
scraping data from the web but the trend
that's actually most interesting to me
is how the breakdown of who's in those
pies is actually changing right so right
now a lot of the people who are actually
getting web data using it for things are
folks who have the programming skills of
the people in this room right they can
sit down and actually write a
web automation script with one of the
web automation libraries that's out
there
but increasingly folks from outside of a
traditional computer science background
are realizing how much value there is
and how much you can actually learn from
real-time data whether it's just about
the quantity you can get whether it's
about the sort of ecological validity
whether it's about
uh basically getting data in real time
all of these are really important for
folks deciding
where to get their data and how to
actually do the analyses that they want
to do
so here are some of the things that our
collaborators are working on in the
space i'm going to just emphasize one of
these right now because we have a
limited time
so basically the the folks on the
sociology side of this collaboration
what they're working on is how to help
low-income families move to high
opportunity neighborhoods
now the background here is that there
are housing voucher programs where the
intention
is to
give housing vouchers to folks from
low-income families
uh if
the the place that they are trying to
rent is under some kind of rent
threshold right they don't want to
overpay because then you can't serve as
many families but
you do have to set the rent threshold in
such a way that there are actually
places in the high opportunity
neighborhoods that fall under that rent
threshold and so if you're relying on
every 10 years census data and you're in
a city where the rents are rising
rapidly
this can be pretty tough pretty quickly
you end up with a point where the the
rent threshold is set in such a way that
only the low income low opportunity
neighborhoods are actually accessible
below that rent threshold and then you
have unintentionally produced a housing
voucher program that is funneling people
into those neighborhoods only
so that's not what we want and what the
folks in this space realized was that
the way they can actually
set those thresholds uh in a data guided
way in a way that's actually going to
adapt to
fast-changing market situations
is to get real-time data from from the
web so in this case they realize that
craigslist and apartments.com are
providing a lot of really uh uh rich
really uh up-to-date data on what are
the prices for uh rental units in this
neighborhood versus this neighborhood
versus this neighborhood
so
we wanted to check out first whether is
a
end user web automation an actual real
nade and so the first thing we do keep
in mind i was mostly on the pl side at
this time i wasn't super promising in
the hci side i didn't know a ton about
how to do need finding and so my first
guess was okay let's let's send out to
an email listserv
is anyone going to need web data and i
expected to maybe get two or three
answers this happened to be a listserv
of folks working from a number of
different social science domains
specifically on urban data but instead
what actually happened was there was a
whole flood of
responses and it was really difficult to
get any work done for the course of the
next 24-ish hours
so basically what we heard from that
is that end user web automation is
indeed a real need right there is data
out there people do want it and they
unfortunately can't get it on their own
right they were responding to our email
because they hadn't been able to
actually get it so far
and so this kicked off a set of need
finding collaborations that would go on
for the next
three-ish four-ish years and some of
them would actually turn into long-term
collaborations with folks in this space
and so the background here the reason
all these folks were uh reaching out to
us and and happy to get involved with
the project is because web automation
programming is really hard so this is
data on basically folks with computer
science phds well folks in computer
science phd programs how quickly were
they able to actually accomplish a
particular web automation programming
task and it turns out that even if you
let them go for an hour
only about a quarter of them were able
to actually complete the task
on the other hand if you give them our
tool they can go ahead and get to 100
completion rate within uh 10 minutes and
in fact this isn't just uh let me do
this tasking this time this is all the
way from i have never heard of the tool
helena before all the way to i have
completed the task
so this is you know everything from
watching the five minute demo video all
the way to actually doing the task
um okay
so
let's quickly go through why this is so
hard right why is this actually such a
challenge so does anyone have a sense of
why this snippet
is not going to work
so the goal here is here's our our web
page and we want to know what the price
is
anyone have a guess
you've hard-coded a price into the code
so if you're trying to find the price
for another item it's not gonna
not gonna do it perfect yeah so this is
not a particularly good way to find the
price of this item right this is a good
way to find the string 26.06
which if the price has changed if we're
on some other products page all of a
sudden that's not going to work so well
so in order to actually figure out how
to get the price on the page over time
you're going to have to do a bunch of
stuff to actually reverse engineer the
page structure right the underlying dom
tree well all right that's pretty hard
but if that ended at there right like
maybe that would still be manageable for
folks
but why is this snippet not going to
work
so here what we want to do is basically
scrape the first item in google's
autocomplete so why is this not going to
work
because there's it's reactive so you
need to wait time between entering the
string and getting the results
super close save that answer okay
anything else
yeah so i said preparing this space was
hard right so the reason is actually
that what's going on under the surface
is not that this just automatically
comes up when a string is put in this
query box instead
because it is in fact a set of
javascript handlers
running and responding to any set of
events you might want them to actually
respond to
what's happening here is on a particular
key entry
event you are going to get the response
that is going to actually create this
and just putting the the string that you
want inside that box will never actually
do this so you could wait forever and
the the
box that actually shows the autocomplete
suggestions is never going to pop up
because you haven't actually triggered
the event that is then going to cause
the javascript handler to run
so in order to make this stuff work you
also have to be reverse engineering the
javascript code that is running on the
page and now what about on this one so
here what we're trying to do is click on
say this product variant and then click
on add to cart in order to get it added
to the cart do you want to reuse your
answer from before
yeah okay so basically the problem here
is that if you are a human user using
this web page what would happen is you
would click on the second variant it
would all get grayed out and that would
be a visual signal to you the human user
that we are waiting for something to
come back to the from the server right
it's going out to try to get some more
information the server is going to
provide us that information and then the
web page is going to get updated we
should wait until that happens
but nothing actually prevents you
as a machine user from going ahead and
pressing the add to cart so if you do
you know line one here and then line two
you will instead add the old item the
old version of the item right whichever
one was previously highlighted into the
cart
and so you'll also have to be reverse
engineering the communication with the
server
so this is pretty tough this is a lot to
ask from even an experienced programmer
as we saw on the slide with the actual
user study results but it's also a lot
to ask from folks who really don't have
this training at all
and so one thing you might be thinking
is well
what if we just watch the user
interacting with the browser it seems
like what's happening is the user is
making some actions this mouse clicks
those key presses those various events
and then this browser is actually going
ahead and serving data back
so what if we just sort of looked at
those actions that the user is doing
pop them into some kind of artificial
user
and go ahead and actually do it that way
and this would be the core idea behind
programming by demonstration which is
the basis of the tool that we're going
to present today
so pvd web automation is a long-standing
dream right people thought about this
general idea ever since it made sense to
talk about uh
netscape navigator and new versions of
windows 95 right this is something that
people have been thinking about
uh and the first thing that they thought
was okay maybe
people are going to want to extract
tables from web pages i'm looking at
this webpage it looks like there's a
table maybe we want to grab that out
the next thing people said was okay
maybe we actually want to record a set
of interactions that the user is doing
and actually replay them for things like
automating tests of web pages that kind
of thing
and then
around 2009
things got a lot harder so for starters
even with web table extraction and web
recording replay we hadn't gotten all
the way to the kinds of programs that
the social scientists i highlighted on a
few slides back were actually able to to
write the programs that they wanted
but also the web got a lot harder so it
became much much more interactive
and that basically made all of the
challenges that everyone was dealing
with in these existing tools
even more complex such that a lot of the
old tools basically broke
so at that point progress basically
stalled
so we're going to do a quick little demo
here and i'm going to first talk through
what is going to happen and then we'll
see the actual demo in practice so what
data should we collect if we want to
learn when cs researchers peak
where would you all look would you look
at a particular web page
yeah i would definitely look at google
scholar so let's start there so what
we're going to do is we're going to go
ahead and open a browser extension
that's our little tool up there i guess
you can see the little text that says
what it is
and then
over here on the left we're going to
have sort of the control pane and on the
right we're going to be interacting with
something that is basically just our
normal browser window but what we're
going to be charged with doing is
demonstrating how to find information
that goes in the first row of our target
data set for all of the tables in our
target data set so say we want to
collect information about authors and
their papers all authors all of their
papers what we're going to do is collect
information about that first author
and then information about the first
paper by the first author
and so all of that is starting to appear
over here on the left
and then when we're done with
demonstrating we can go ahead and leave
it to the tool to actually write the
program for us right so here we have
something that is going to loop over the
authors it is going to loop over the
papers you can see here it has some nice
names for things in the papers table it
doesn't know about names for the authors
table but it's happy to scrape them
anyway
and then the program is going to go
ahead and collect our data so now i'll
go ahead and let us actually watch the
demo so here's what it actually looks
like when you're doing this
collecting that sample data we're going
to go ahead and let the tool actually
write the program for us it has gone
ahead and decided what to do it is ready
to collect our data
all right and you can see it's collected
the first couple hundred rows
so now we rewind i hope that after
seeing that demo you're saying to
yourself
boy it really seems like end user web
automation and program synthesis
technology is pretty usable and though
so why would we be
in this situation so long where the
actual reactions to pvd for web
automation were you know it wasn't
getting adopted it wasn't getting used
it just wasn't a good space yet
so let's take a look through some of the
work that had happened before so this is
from a really beautiful paper by tessa
lao in 2008 which is basically looking
at uh okay what's what's going on with
these programming by demonstration
systems that don't work out so well
what's the things that it's happening
and one of the things she noticed was
that repetitive demonstrations were a
big obstacle for people if they could
say okay i really just want to change
this tiny little thing and i can
describe the change in natural language
it's really frustrating to go back and
give my seventh repetitive demonstration
and over here she was uh this is
actually also a test allowed paper she
was figuring out that sort of switching
between multiple different kinds of
demonstrations that they had to give was
very confusing and over in the excel
flashflow space excel uh flash fill is
actually sort of the big success story
of program synthesis the most used
program synthesizer that is out there
right now and one of the things they
realized as they were productionizing
and putting it into excel
is that if you actually want this to be
useful you usable then it really has to
get the right answer after a single
demonstration a single example and this
was sort of very intensely enforced that
it had to be able to do that for most of
the real queries that they thought
people were going to be doing
and so there are a couple problems here
so one
were these tools these existing tools
useful were they helping the target
audience do the tasks they actually
wanted or needed to do
and we really just hadn't gotten there
yet right we aren't just trying to grab
tables we aren't just trying to record a
particular interaction and replay that
same interaction that's not what we're
looking to do
and was it usable and so no and basis on
on what we're seeing from those uh sort
of
failure and semi-success stories we're
seeing that even though we're starting
to have vbe tools it's not enough to
have them be programming by example or
programming by demonstration that's not
enough to actually make them usable
so let's diagnose real quick what's
going wrong there's actually a common
thread running through all three of
these stories
so here they were frustrated about
giving really repetitive demonstrations
here they were confused by the need for
having multiple different kinds of
demonstrations that would all come
together to produce one program and here
they want to get the right answer after
just one example
so i think after looking at this you'll
say to yourself well
it seems like if we could just do
everything from a single demonstration
if we only get one example then maybe
the user is going to be happy
and so that's what we asked ourselves
was could we do pbd with just one
demonstration
now
doing it with a single demonstration is
crazy if you're a program of this person
right you look at that specification
that you're getting from the user and
you say oh boy that is just way too
ambiguous it could be that after giving
that demonstration the user right the
demonstration is you know first author
first paper by first author so maybe
they want the first paper by each author
maybe they want all the papers by all
the authors
maybe they want all the papers with more
than a particular number of citations
all the papers that mention learning in
the title right all of those are
consistent with that single
demonstration that we actually gave
so the observation that ended up driving
our approach is that
drafting programs is really hard for
these users
as it turns out however
editing is easy right
they've had this particular set of
training in some amount of programming a
lot of them have had about one semester
of python or r data analysis
even in those spaces where they've had
training they don't actually just sit
down with a blank page right they have
this blank page syndrome it's very
intimidating to sit down with the open
editor window and they're not going to
just go ahead and sit down and write out
a new data analysis script from scratch
but what they are going to do is take
the program that they used in class the
program that their collaborator is using
and adapt it for the tasks that they're
trying to do right now
and so that's basically the observation
that we were able to to
produce our approach around so
one thing here is we're going to need to
make editable programs right calling
back to this quote here we really do
if we are going to do it this way
we need to make sure that the user can
actually read understand and modify the
programs that they're getting back from
the synthesizer
so what will make the tool usable so
one thing is it has to be single
demonstration has to be editable we had
definitely not reached that point so far
in the in the pvd history
so nope not yet
and so our approach here was rather than
doing the traditional pbd workflow where
you put in a bunch of demonstrations the
synthesis algorithm takes it turns it
into a program then you run the program
you pop out the output
the user debugs by looking at the output
and thinks about is that the right
output if they're not happy with it they
put in another demonstration
we get rid of that workflow and instead
we do a demonstrate once revised anytime
workflow where the idea is the user puts
in one demonstration the synthesis
algorithm produces a program it may not
be exactly the program the user is going
to want in the end
but it's close enough that the user can
now edit it until it reaches the point
where the the user is happy with it
so this is the the single demonstration
element this is the editable program
element that's what we think we need in
order to reach usability
so let's talk quickly about why one demo
really is so much better than two
demonstrations
so obviously we've already talked about
the fact that it makes for happy
successful users
another thing is it actually changes the
constraints on us the developers of the
synthesizer so one of the big challenges
in synthesis is if you have to reach
every single point in the program space
that's a really really massive search
space and it's really hard to actually
do that so we get to relax that because
we can just reach some of the points in
the program space as long as they are
close enough via edits
to the program that the user is going to
want in the end
another thing is it changes all the
extra infrastructure we have to build up
around the synthesizer so we don't have
to do this ambiguity detection layer or
this demonstration solicitation
interface anymore
and then another thing is it changes the
programs that you can actually use
programming by demonstration for so
whereas in the past you really couldn't
do
long-running programs now we can and so
why couldn't we do long-running programs
in the past well
if the way that you're going to debug it
is by running it looking at the output
seeing if the output is right and if
your web automation program that you're
trying to run is going to run for you
know three days
boy that's going to be really hard to
actually land on the one that you were
looking for
fortunately in this case where we're
actually presenting them programs that
they can look at they can debug it does
become reasonable for them to actually
debug even very long running programs
so
the way that we are going to reach this
this door approach is by developing
usable drafting tools and learnable
languages of course these are also
usable outside useful and usable outside
of uh dora workflows we just happen to
be talking about them in the context of
this one workflow so on the usable
drafting tools the techniques that we
ended up using in developing
were program synthesizers dialog based
program augmentation interfaces
and then on the learnable languages side
we spent a lot of time on reverse
compilation and bi-level dsls and some
custom language abstractions i'm not
going to dive into all of these but i'm
going to do a quick tour through a few
of these
so i'm going to highlight goal 1 and
goal 3 today let's start with how we
synthesize complex programs from a
single demonstration
so we knew that what users need this was
based on some of that need finding work
with with real folks in this space
uh we knew that people needed multi-load
data so this is stuff that is accessed
by clicking interacting with forms doing
widget interactions right all the stuff
that you do when you're interacting with
the web on a day-to-day basis they need
to do in order to collect their data
it's also looking for hierarchical data
so the data they want isn't just give me
the list of all authors it's give me the
list of all authors and all of their
papers right we have all of this
hierarchical type data that they're
looking to get
and so those are the constraints that we
definitely needed to make in order for
the the tool to come out useful to them
unfortunately this is going to be a
little bit hard so we know that we need
to actually get this kind of data we
definitely know that the tools that were
out there were not there yet
um but why is it actually hard well
if you're a program synthesizer you're
probably already getting a program
synthesis person you're probably already
getting nervous when you realize that
you're going to need nested loops right
the nested loops are sort of one of the
the banes of
program synthesis in general
and if you think about it as sort of
how it expands the space of programs
that you're searching this makes a lot
of sense right so if you think about
only the programs that have no loops
well that is a massive set obviously
but it's somewhat manageable it's
somewhat reasonable in size
if you start thinking about all the
programs that have one loop well you're
already up to a much bigger set that's
starting to look a little nerve-wracking
and in fact a lot of program
synthesizers cannot have handle programs
that even have one loop
if you're allowing multiple loops
boy now it's really getting intense the
search space is massive and it's going
to be pretty tough to actually search
that space
and so we hit this little fork in the
road
where we could go down the path of
trying to make a smarter faster
synthesizer right this is the thing that
people have traditionally tried when
they have tackled this problem afresh
or is there some other way what else
could we do other than just try to make
a smarter faster synthesizer
and so the the thing that we eventually
started thinking about was there are
lots of different demonstrations that
you could give
in order to show a human user the kinds
of data that you're trying to collect so
in our little working example here maybe
they go ahead and play around with a
couple of the papers from this author
and then they show the list page
that author appeared and they scrape the
various things that they're going to
want
that's a good demonstration it would
probably serve to explain to a human
user what you're trying to actually
collect but another way you can do it is
the way we did it in the the demo that
you saw where first we collect
information about that first author then
we collect information about the first
paper by that first author
these are two very different
demonstrations and as it turns out one
of them is going to make it much easier
for the program synthesizer to actually
do their job so if we allow all possible
demonstrations we really don't have any
better approach than just searching
through the whole space of programs
until we land on one that produces the
data that the user has collected
on the other hand if we restrict it to
demonstrations like the one on the right
we can be a bit smarter
so basically we can limit the user a
little bit in order to make the
synthesizer design much easier and the
idea here is basically entering into a
contract with the user
to get them to produce something that's
synthesizer friendly right for this
class of synthesizer friendly things we
know that we can build a synthesizer
that is going to turn things in that
class into the output programs that we
want
for things outside of it we just don't
know how to build that synthesizer yet
but of course we can go too far right
we've seen a bunch of synthesizers that
were doing things that enforced
synthesizer friendliness like demanding
a bunch of demonstrations and that
crossed to the point where it was not
user friendly anymore so what we want of
course is something that's going to sit
at that intersection
and basically the way that we found to
enforce this is just to have a contract
with the user that will allow us to make
a
simpler synthesis process
so the contract with the user we
wouldn't explain it to them in quite
this way of course but the basics of it
is that you want to demonstrate the
first iteration of each loop
or you can also think of it as the first
row of each table that you're going to
be using or collecting
and you want it to be ordered from outer
inner loop and we're actually helped
along this process by the fact that the
web mostly enforces that you order from
outer to inner loop the way you navigate
links
so this contract reduces the synthesis
problem to a much smaller problem
because basically all we're having to do
is take this straight line program that
you see on the right and decide where
should we add loops and over what
and so let's start by assuming that we
actually know what are the tables of
interest this is a big assumption we'll
think about it again in a second but if
we assume that we know this
we can go ahead and say okay this line
relates to authors this line relates to
papers and basically all we have to do
is go ahead and add a loop that goes
before the first use of any of the cells
of a given table and ends after the last
use right so here we go we've added in
the appropriate loops
now we do actually have to find those
tables right so assuming we know about
the
tables is a big assumption
which interacted nodes though are part
of a table on a page and which aren't so
for this one who thinks that all of the
highlighted and red nodes
are part of a table that shows up on the
page
even if it's just a logical table
yeah i agree right so we see that these
elements all seem to be part of one row
it seems like the
the related elements on the next row
would be maybe this this and this it
seems like there's basically a logical
table set up here
what about for this one does it seem
like there's another row of this same
kind of data on this same page
yeah i agree seems like no
seems like no
what about this one
yeah i'm getting some sort of like uh
partially right like it seems like these
two probably aren't part of it but these
ones do seem like okay those probably
correspond to here and so basically the
approach that we ended up using was
formalizing basically the intuition that
you're having right now i'm going to
gloss over the actual table selector
synthesis problem a little bit but
basically it looks like this we just
want to use that same insight that youth
hal had about which elements that the
user interacted with
seem like
they they have corresponding elements in
a similar structure right now the the
computer isn't looking at it sort of
visually the way we are but it's looking
at the underlying dom structure to see
if there are similarities
and so this has simplified the the
process of doing the synthesis pretty
dramatically so we've gone from having
to search the space of all programs in
the hell in a language to the much more
constrained problem of actually
synthesizing table selectors more doable
and more manageable
and rather than asking the user to
reverse engineer the webpage we are
instead just asking them to learn this
demonstration contract right it's not
nothing but it's more manageable
and users do indeed perceive helena to
be more usable than hear the the
comparison is selenium which is a
traditional
web automation library
uh and also uh substantially more
learnable
and also of course users are more
successful with helena so this was the
big thing was we are most excited for
them to be able to do these tasks that
they they want to do
uh without running into too many
obstacles
and yeah i did want to emphasize again
that these times include training time
we actually let them do anything they
wanted for training so they basically
just had free range with the with the
docs
uh most of them did end up watching a
five-minute
demonstration video before they actually
started and that's still uh even with
that they end up in this under ten
minute time
okay i'm actually going to go ahead and
skip over most of this goal three
section so we have a little more time to
talk about the the broader vision but
basically this was sort of switching
over from looking at usable drafting
tools to looking over learnable
languages and one of the big obstacles
is that it's actually pretty tough
to get both robustness and usability
because for robustness you need to get
all of this stuff into the program and
boy you really don't want to show that
to even a programmer
you definitely don't want to show it to
a non-programmer right this is gross we
don't want to show that we much rather
show
something that looks like this right
that's much more friendly that's
something that the the user might
actually be comfortable looking at and
editing so how do we actually deal with
the fact that we need this low level
language for robust replay but we really
want to show the user something more
like this
who thinks we should sacrifice
robustness
readability
yeah right that's not very satisfying we
would much rather just have both and so
the way that we actually have both
is by showing the users a high-level
view where it looks like this but still
maintaining the low-level view that we
have in order to actually run it and
this is this bi-level dsl idea sorry dsl
is domain-specific language
where what we have is this
representation that looks quite friendly
but it's actually being mapped from a
low level language right we have a
reverse compiler that's going ahead and
taking it to the the version that we
want to show users and then as the user
makes changes at the upper level it can
go ahead and be propagated back down to
the low level code via our custom
program editor and of course there's
some statements that don't even need
that because they actually don't
interact with the web
so this lets us synthesize these very
huge very messy but still edible
editable programs
okay from here i want to i want to move
on to talking a bit about
the
impact that this project other projects
in this general space the various
programming tools that we've been
building
have had on our vision for drawing on
hci and pl work
so like i said a lot of what we're
focused on a lot of what we've been
doing is working on programming tools
for social scientists and domain experts
from other non-technical domains
i'm going to use social sciences as sort
of a catch-all term but i really should
read this as folks from domains other
than computing who need programming for
something
and what we're seeing of course is that
there are so many people who want not
just data right that was sort of the
motivation for the earlier part of the
helena bit of the talk
but automation in some form computation
in some form
and right now a lot of those people who
want that are computer scientists
we're going to keep seeing a bunch of
computer scientists want data probably
even more but we're seeing so many
non-computer scientists who are wanting
and needing it
and we really feel that hdipl hybrid
work can help us here
if we can go ahead and actually make
programming languages useful and usable
for real users
and so i talked about this briefly early
on but i i want to talk about it again
now that we've seen sort of how the
helena tool came together
we really want to move away from this
evaluative only approach to using hci
techniques in pl it's really been a few
decades now of folks mostly
you know coming to their hci colleagues
when they have done with a tool and they
want to get it evaluated right from from
pl that's sort of the the common mode is
okay i've built my thing i know i should
eventually see if it works for users
let's see once it's done if it worked
and what we found in in the process of
this project and the various other
projects in this space
is that we really benefit from doing a
lot of need finding right working with
real users and seeing what are they
doing right now what is working what is
not working
what kinds of things are they
comfortable talking about versus not
talking about i didn't talk about how we
helped these programmers actually
parallelize their programs but the way
we actually did that uh was by noticing
that they were very comfortable doing
data deduplication and stealing all the
information they would use for that and
actually using that to parallelize and
distribute their programs which is
something that we just wouldn't have
even thought to do if we hadn't been
there hearing about their their data
deduplication processes
so doing that need finding has really
served both the the tool design and the
abstraction design really enriching both
the the programming tools and the
programming languages
and another thing i want to emphasize
this iterative refinement process
even through you know this this project
this particular project has gone on for
a number of years now and
we definitely were discovering
additional things that we needed to
augment things that we needed to modify
you know years and years into the
process doing this iterative process is
what produced the the tool that actually
you know a bunch of people are using
quite regularly like the the sociology
example that i gave earlier they are now
at this point collecting rental data
from 100
major metropolitan areas around the us
every single day around the clock
um and using this to shape housing
voucher programs so this kind of thing
works because we actually did this
iterative process with folks to get at
what does it actually take to to make
these tools usable for them
and it has turned out to be a really
impressive way to to find sort of
interesting and exciting uh programming
language challenges right so in the
programming languages space
uh there there's a bunch of value given
on just describing a fresh problem this
is sort of a magical way to just pop
them out without even really having to
to
uh you know do do a lot of sort of hard
thinking yourself you get to just watch
people see what they are actually
struggling with and basically out of
thin air produce these these really
exciting challenges because so often the
the programming languages techniques
that are already out there have not
actually reached the point of solving
the problems that these real users have
and so we really get this interesting
way of
coming up with new fun challenges to
solve with the programming languages
techniques
and we have a bunch of ideas for where
this is going going forward so the needs
of novice coders and non-coders the
needs that they have they're so diverse
right it's all these different things
that they want to do
and one of the big things that we want
to see going forward is that we're
actually going to start soliciting more
different kinds of input from the users
there's been this big focus on
basically examples sometimes
demonstrations although that has been
fairly rare
and we really think that's just not the
the only things that are out there the
only ways for users to express their
intentions and we have this sort of
programming by x vision of what is it
that is going to be natural for the
programmer programmer in quotes to
express to us and how can we use that to
actually get to the program that they
need
okay so how this looks so far i'm going
to talk about how this has been shaping
our current ongoing projects
um
i promise to get to the question prime
of the of the thing within the next two
minutes
uh so we have a bunch of ongoing need
finding right i emphasized how important
need finding has been for our work so
far and it really it's it's a huge part
of our mission going forward is before
we start diving in and trying to tackle
the programming needs of these audiences
let's go in and actually see what
they're doing right now let's see what's
working let's see if it's not working
and so parker's project right now he's
looking at basically what people are
doing with geospatial data this is
everyone from people who are already
super comfortable using programming
tools in the space
to people who are mostly using graphical
user interfaces to people who are just
uh beginning to start using graphical
user interfaces and are still kind of
wandering around trying to figure it out
and he's focused especially on folks
from three domains so environmental
scientists journalists and social
scientists and what he's figuring out is
that a lot of the challenges that they
have they actually do share
but of course some of them are quite
different
another thing is that it's been really
interesting to see how much these these
very same techniques work on people as
sort of the other end of the spectrum
for for some definition of the spectrum
right if these gis users are mostly
folks who really haven't been taught a
lot of programming the the people on the
functional programming side are at least
often the stereotype is that they're
kind of the
nerdiest of the nerdy programming
language users
um so so we really get to to see the
spectrum and seeing the same techniques
working for for folks all the way from
from the least experienced to the most
experienced uh and then also we have
lisa who's working on some really cool
stuff for a domain that i barely even
knew existed until recently which is
climate economists
so figuring out what are the needs
across these spaces
i want to mention a couple of things
here
so one is that thing that i mentioned of
sort of how these techniques really can
span the spectrum so especially when i'm
speaking with programming languages
audiences i really emphasize that hey
you may see me doing all this work on
the the social sciences side and the
non-technical domain expert side but
look this also applies equally to
functional programmers whatever audience
it is that you are trying to build
programming tools for you can use these
same approaches to figure out their
needs as well
and then also the fact that it's just
quite a diverse array of non-coders
right so we are figuring out that
audiences that we wouldn't even
necessarily thought of as having
automation challenges absolutely are
running into them right so
probably folks suspected that
journalists were having this kind of
need but i don't know if folks were
expecting social scientists and climate
economists to need a bunch of automation
maybe you were maybe i'm just sort of in
the dark there but yeah so we're getting
all of these different folks with all
these very different needs and it's
really exciting to see the different
needs that are coming out of these these
findings
okay and this really brings us back
again to my favorite little slide here
on why i think need finding is so
important
i also wanted to talk a bit about some
of the tools that are already getting
built up so in particular helena here is
working on tooling for journalists and
rebecca is working on tooling for
lawyers
both of these tools so far are coming
out of a larger project on processing
really large
really messy
unstructured data about police
misconduct
so basically this is part of a
collaboration with folks from the
national association of criminal defense
lawyers one of the things they're
dealing with is
the sites that they work with the
defense lawyers that they work with they
know that some of the police who are
testifying against their clients have
previously lied on the stand or have
other patterns of misconduct and that's
important for judges and juries to know
to have more complete information and so
one of the things that these students
are doing is both working really closely
with the folks in this space so uh
helena is actually working with a bunch
of journalists including some who work
right here at stanford uh and rebecca is
working super closely with both the
nacdl and with a bunch of the defense
offices that they actually integrate
with
and so they're working on tools that
will basically make it doable for folks
to go from these big piles of messy
unstructured data into the structured
data that then lawyers journals can use
to actually make their analyses to
figure out if a particular person's
testimony should be trusted and that
kind of thing
so this is part of a really exciting
ongoing project and one of the main
collaborators here is the dt parmesan
there's a bunch of really fun stuff
happening in this space this is only one
tiny sliver of it
okay i promised i would get the
questions and now i'm ready to get the
questions um i would love to talk about
either helena but i think probably the
most interesting thing for us to discuss
is sort of this broadable broader uh
message about how we're pulling in
techniques from hci into pl but i'm
happy to discuss whatever is exciting to
to this crowd
[Applause]
we will have questions in the room and
we will also have some questions online
sean can help us with the questions that
come from online that sounds great that
sounds great
oh so i think i saw your hand first do
you wanna um so great talk it was really
excellent i love your work um one thing
that i want to ask more about is when
you're working in the iterative design
process with all these like non-coders
and developing your synthesizers like
how are you thinking about power and i
guess i ask this because like as someone
who builds tools for a lot of non-coders
myself like i'm always
like sharply aware of like oh like i
have all these skills of programming and
stuff and while i want to like help
these people i don't want to do so in a
way that is like sort of like
imperialist um yeah so how are you like
sort of thinking about that as well yeah
we think about that a lot honestly
especially the more we're moving into
spaces where
there's there's really huge implications
for whether these tools serve these
audiences right especially i was
mentioning the police misconduct data in
case right this is a case where the the
usability of this tool whether a defense
attorney can use it within the five
hours they have to prepare this person's
case
that might mean the difference between
calling out that you know a judge has
previously found that this person lied
on the stand or not
um
so a lot of what it has turned into for
us is
being really clear about what our goals
are
being really clear getting from them a
really clear statement about what their
goals are making sure before we really
enter into the collaboration that those
are enough aligned that we both think we
can meet some of our goals
and just being really straightforward
about the the fact that you know
research timelines are a little
unpredictable and there are a lot of
promises we just can't make for them
so i think that's been been the big
thing and then
another huge thing for us has been the
fact that
we basically
when we ask them to share anything with
us uh you know data is the normal place
where people talk about this but often
for us it's even just sort of their time
their process the the chance to actually
observe them
we do make it clear in advance that this
may never actually end up helping them
if the the tool design goes down another
road right this may only help uh people
in a related space and and we never get
around to the particular challenge that
they are going to end up demonstrating
for us
uh so yeah a lot of really open
communication and being really clear
about what they should expect from us
thanks for the question
uh we have a question
near me
yes
faculty i've tried many of these tools
over the years and in fact i think i
have a publication on one at some point
um
and they always seem to break
when i try real cases even flash fill
you know
sometimes doesn't do what i expect and
can't debug why is it not doing it
um
so the idea of producing code as
something you can edit is an interesting
idea but that idea goes back actually to
some of the earliest programming like
demonstration systems in fact one of the
famous ones produced list code
and the barrier to that was
most users can't program so are your
users you're assuming people have had
you know at least you know a half year
or a year of programming knowledge to
understand that because otherwise
you know it's not usable for that reason
so i wanted to understand that
assumption about who they end users are
so when you say end users often
people it means anybody on the street
could do it and you know it's unclear
looking at code even if it looks like
scratch um
yeah i i love this question so this has
definitely i mean
you know the reason i
the reason i emphasized the the
learnable languages element of it in
addition to the program synthesizer end
of it is exactly because we've had all
these problems with tools that are
producing say lisp right you can't
expect someone to just sit down and pick
that up in one sitting
on the other hand
it seems like if we're in a particular
restricted domain like for example web
automation
where we can really match the
abstractions that the user is having to
understand to the abstractions that they
are thinking about when they are doing
this task by hand
it seems like we can get people to to
actually pick it up now
i'm going to preface what i'm about to
say by saying that it's anecdotal right
so we haven't done something where
because we are so interested especially
in serving social scientists and because
all the ones we've interacted with
actually have had some amount of
programming training our formal user
studies actually do not cover any cases
where it's just you know i have never
programmed before having said that
you know this tool has been around for a
while and we actually have supportive
folks who have literally no programming
training in getting up and running with
it and we've even done that thing of
okay let me sit down next to this artist
and say how would you do task xyz
if i give you no instruction and they
have figured out how to actually edit
the programs to do that again purely
anecdotal i don't want to say that this
is like a really you know well supported
a claim about this tool but it
definitely gives me hope that this is a
direction that will actually make it
possible for folks who really have no
programming background at all to get up
and running with this kind of tool i
really do think if we can surface the
the program that comes out
and make it in a language that they can
actually understand with really no
training at all i think we're on a good
path but yeah i know i completely agree
that this is one of the huge obstacles
to this style of tool
um could you talk a little bit more
about how you find collaborators who you
think have interesting needs and you
talked a little bit already about like
setting clear expectations and making
sure your goals are aligned but like how
are you reaching out to people initially
how are you building trust with them so
they'll let you like see their data and
their problems i love this question
uh
so recently we've gotten somewhat lucky
that because we have a little bit of a
track record people are coming to us
obviously that's not a good sort of
general trick
so the biggest thing that we have done
honestly is have many many conversations
right so
we might have 10 discussions with folks
in a given space and it turns out that
one of those turns into
a a collaboration or turns out to have a
instance of the particular problem that
we are currently equipped to to solve
um
so that's been a huge part of it for
just finding the right people in the
first place is given that we have some
sense of the space in which we're going
to be building
how do we like
talk to a bunch of people in order to
find people who are or their goals are
going to be pretty well aligned with our
goals
so that's a big thing for sure
and then once we have
entered into a particular space and are
working with a few collaborators in
terms of building trust the the biggest
thing is again the open communication
the second biggest thing is if we
have some kind of prototype or can build
them some kind of hand-tuned thing
right something specifically for their
needs even if it hasn't solved the
general problem yet that is often enough
to to make the process worthwhile to
them even in the short term
and then they start to see what would be
the benefits of getting the the tool in
the longer term and they're willing to
actually go ahead and stick it out with
us because they see that how valuable
that's going to be for them
right so in in
you know the the the case of something
like a
data extraction tool right if we can
write them a hand-tuned data extractor
for their particular data set and say is
this the kind of data you're looking for
right this is this is something that
serves both them and us right we we
learn more about is this actually the
kind of data they're looking for
is the the input that they would
actually need in order for us to
generate that kind of program something
that they can provide for us so we're
learning a lot out of it they are
actually getting the sort of end process
data that they want out of it everybody
wins so that's been a big thing for us
yeah
um two questions i'm glad you went first
um
first question is like kind of related
to prayers where like you said you had a
lot of people coming to you asking for
collaborations how do you decide filter
of like who you collaborate like
assuming like the number you have is
much more than you even have the number
to talk to right um and then the second
question goes on like a little bit in
terms of like creation to uh not by
implementation but like study and review
and iterate right so like you created
this program you did a formal user study
and like it's available to download are
you still monitoring what that is seeing
how people are doing supporting it like
what are like the follow-ups from there
i love both of those questions
so on the on the side of how do we
choose who who to end up actually
collaborating with a lot of it is just
about okay does the the goal of this
particular collaborator align with
something that the students who are
working on this project are really
passionate about right so they're going
to be most excited to to do work on
something that sort of aligns with their
values and their goals in life so that's
huge for us for sure
another big thing that we enforce that
we're we're filtering for is that the
the tools that we are competent to
produce are actually going to be useful
to them right like it would be great to
work with someone who you know their
their sort of big push that they're
working on is something that's
completely aligned with my my you know
absolute favorite cause or right like
that's great but if the the tools that
we are actually going to be able to
build
aren't the the last sort of remaining
barrier between them and the thing
they're trying to accomplish
it probably doesn't make sense for us to
to be there with them right we're just
gonna end up disappointing them when
that actually doesn't get them to to
their goals
and so that's that's a big thing that we
enforce that we filter on in and so far
we haven't reached the point where
there's so many people who are really
well you know
aligned with programming tools goals
that we're ready to get up and running
on right away maybe someday that will
happen and then we'll have to have more
of a more of a filter yeah that's a big
thing for now can you remind me of the
second question
on how you understand it was extremely
helpful compared to what was currently
out there and it's already available
like to download are you in any way
supporting or like continuing to measure
progress um the stuff you said about
antidote are you getting more data on
that as more people download about the
future
i love this question yeah so this
actually relates to to one of the
questions that uh uh we get pretty often
which
is sort of how do you feel about
telemetrics of some kind built into
programming tools programming languages
even
um
so i i think there's
there's a lot of reasonable sort of
approaches to have uh towards how much
are you willing to watch your users
we have personally chosen
not to do a lot of recording of what
they are doing with our programming tool
this is for a number of reasons so one
is the the expectations around how much
data is collected about you when you're
using a programming tool compared to
when you're using say a web page are
quite different at this point it would
be pretty unusual to have data collected
about you when you're just using a tool
we have started to go down the road of
if you opt in we will collect some data
not for this particular tool but for for
another tool in a related study
but really only if you know you're
you're opting in pretty regularly we
make sure that there's interfaces for
you to go in and say okay no i need this
bit to be
cleared back out let me search for this
string and make sure that has never
appeared go ahead and wipe that bit of
the data right so there's a lot of extra
infrastructure that we have to build up
in order to
sort of
in a way that is respectful of their
uh process and of their needs uh
actually collect extra information about
them outside of a study
setting yeah that was more of like a
number of downloads and stuff like that
or maybe surveys of like are they
like the similar things when you
download like a regular program or
something they match number of people
download sometimes they ask are you
student are you able to see who's down
in terms of that not like seeing what
they search
yeah yeah so
actually the way that folks get the the
helena tool in particular is through the
chrome web store so we actually don't
have a control over sort of what data
we're collecting from them that all kind
of happens invisibly to us
now having said that there are
definitely people who reach out for
support and so for those folks we
actually do end up getting a lot of
information about okay who is it who's
coming to this so far
now that's only a subset who knows who
it is who's opting into actually getting
in touch with us that's not going to be
a representative sample but it gives us
some idea of okay who's getting up and
running with this right now
so
formally not a lot of follow-up on that
informally some follow up on that
um sarah unfortunately we are out of
time
thank you so much
oh thank you so much this is super fun
to chat with y'all
[Applause]
you